الان من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح
مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام تحديث اذا
لخر الاستهدافات والضربات الاسرائيليه في
اكثر من مكان
وربما كيف يصل ايضا ضحايا اثر هذا القصف
والضربات الاسرائيليه الى المستشفى حيث
انت بالفعل ما بين فينه واخرى تصل اعداد
من الاصابات جراء استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي وربما اخر الغارات التي رصدها
شهود عيان وحتى الان لم تصل الاصابات من
جرائها هي تلك التي استهدفت مجموعه من
المواطنين في منطقه المغرا في شمال مخيم
النصيرات حيث استهدفت على ما يبدو طائره
مسيره بصاروخ مجموعه من المواطنين كانت
تغادر هذه المنطقه التي تشهد منذ عده ايام
قصف مدفعي اسرائيلي من قبل الدبابات
والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه
على اطرافها بالتالي الطائرات المسيره
باتت تكثف من الغارات الاسرائيليه باتجاه
هذه المناطق وباتجاه مناطق مختلفه كما حدث
في خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه عندما استهدفت
طائره مسيره ايضا مجموعه من المواطنين
كانوا يحاولون تعبئه بعض جالونات المياه
فاستشهد عدد من المواطنين جراء هذا
الاستهداف ايضا اطلاق النار على طفل داخل
منطقه حي الامل وبالتحديد في مركز ايواء
تابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني واستشهد طفل
جراء هذا الاستهداف من طائره مسيره كذلك
كان هناك استهداف من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه في مخيم البريج واستشهد عدد
من الفلسطينيين من بينهم سيده من جراء هذا
الاستهداف وبالتالي الاستهدافات من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه من قبل
الطائرات المسيره ايضا مستمره لكنها ربما
تكون الكثافه في هذه الاستهدافات هي في
مدينه غزه وفي شمال القطاع لا سما في
جباليا وفي مخيم جباليا وبالتالي
الاستهداف في تلك المناطق ربما يكون اكثر
خصوصيه لا سما في ظل تواجد الجيش
الاسرائيلي محاصرته لتلك المناطق عدم وصول
سيارات اسعاف وسيارات دفاع مدني الى تلك
المناطق وحتى
المصبين عف المقاطعه فقط من الضروري ان
نوه لهذه الاخبار العاجله دائما بحسب
معاريف عن نائب رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
السابق يقول نحن لا نقول الحقيقه
لمواطنينا ولن نقضي على حزب الله ويضيف
حماس الوحيده القادره على اطلاق
سراح المختطفين يعني هذه اخر اذا تصريحات
على صحيفه معاريف دائما عن نائب رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيلي السابق وبالتاكيد
سيكون هناك المزيد لاحقا و تحليل ونقاش
ايضا بشان هذه التصريحات الملفته اعود
اليك
هشام بالفعل اذا هو قصف اسرائيلي مستمر
ومتواصل سواء من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
التي تواصل قصفها للمناطق التي تتمركز
فيها القوات الاسرائيليه لا سما في شمال
قطع غزه في منطقه بيت حنون ومنطقه بيت لا
هيه والنقطه المركزيه والتي تشهد قصفا
عنيفا وعمليات اشتباك متواصله ما بين قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
وهي بلده جباليا ومخيم جباليا وهذه
المناطق تشهد مجازر اسرائيليه كما رصد
الزملاء هناك عندما انسحبت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه واعادت التموضع والتمركز في
مناطق مختلفه عن تلك التي كانت متواجده
فيها لا سما في محيط المستشفى الاندونيسي
في محيط مستشفى العوده وايضا في حي تل
الزعتر بالتالي اكتشف السكان مجازر عديده
نفذتها الدبابات الاسرائيليه التي داست
على بعض الشهداء وايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعدم بعض المواطنين الفلسطينيين عشرات من
هؤلاء اعدمهم بحسب المؤسسات الحقوقيه
الفلسطينيه والدوليه وبحسب ما رصد رصدنا
من خلال شهود العيان وبالتالي هذه المنطقه
باتت هي الساحه المركزيه لعمليات التوغل
الاسرائيليه لعمليات اطلاق النار وايضا
القصف الاسرائيلي فيما لا يزال قوات
احتلال اسرائيليه و دبابات اسرائيليه
متوغل في تلك المناطق وحتى انها تفصل
المربعات السكنيه عن بعضها البعض في غزه
القصف مكثف في حي الشجاعيه والمناطق
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه لا سما حي الشجاعيه حي
التفاح وايضا حي الزيتون يشهد ما بين
الفينه والاخرى قصف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه التي تقصف في جل استهدافات
المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه وحي الشجاعيه
ربما هو حي متشابه مع ما يجري فيه مشابه
لما يجري في جباليا لا سما وان القصف مكثف
ايضا سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع
المدني لا تستطيع الوصول الى المصابين
والى الشهداء وحتى من يزالون تحت الانقاض
لا تستطيع طواقم الدفاع المدني الوصول
اليهم وانتشالهم او اجلاء مصابين من تحت
الانقاض ربما ايضا الاحوال تتشابه في
المناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس في بني سهيله
وخزاعه والقرار وعبس وهذه المناطق ايضا
يتوغل فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي وما زالت
الاشت ش بكات مستمره الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحاصر هذه المناطق يمنع الدخول اليها
ويمنع الخروج منها غارات ما بين الفينه
والاخرى تطلقها وتشن الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى التحليق المكثف
للمسيرات في تلك المناطق واطلاقها على
النار على كل شيء يتحرك في تلك المناطق
وبالتالي من يصاب ومن يستشهد في تلك
المنطقه يبقى هناك على الارض ملقى دون ان
تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف الوصول اليه وحتى
المواطنين المتواجدين في تلك المناطق لا
يستطيعون اجلاء المصابين او حتى اجلائهم
وتوجه من خلال توجههم الى المستشفيات هي
هم لا يستطيعون الوصول اصلا الى
المستشفيات وهذه الاحوال بكل تاكيد تنعكس
بشكل رئيسي وخطير على الاحوال المعيشيه
لهؤلاء في المناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس في
حي الشجاعيه في منطقه شمال قطاع غزه ولعل
مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع تشهد اوضاع كارثيه
بسبب عدم دخول مساعدات الى تلك المناطق
المواد التموينيه نفذت المواد الغذائيه
نفذت لا يوجد دقيق ولا يوجد اي شيء متوفر
من المواد الاساسيه والمواد التموينيه حتى
المياه غير متوفره وبالتالي الاحوال
المعيشيه هناك كارثيه وتسوء يوما بعد اخر
هشام زقوط من دير البلح اشكرك